[Music]
that's gorgeous
yeah these are the prototypes before the
scale version so this isn't the
nootropic soda in there it's just uh
it looks great man it looks wonderful
i just adore this man i just think this
is amazing so poetic
gorgeous
thanks for doing this with us this is
really cool man this is really cool
so our idea was really that this little
shoe kind of just brings to life this
photo of it
you know it's almost like if we were to
capture that moment again what would
that be like if like we caught you in
that kind of meditative moment with the
pigeons
i would love it you know you have a few
minutes before they're ready for you
you're still setting everything up that
smells great um and then uh
maybe just get a little establishing of
you and then like we'll save it to the
end but maybe we can get you like
holding it and just talking about why
it's a cool thing you got the special
bird fluid perfect
[Applause]
actually walk to your right
and take a breath
and cut
thank you
now we're going to do a quick lens
change we'll come back into a couple
other ones step back and then come back
in so the focus racks off him